[Musique]
info ou intox avec anthony st léger
bonjour bonjour à peine bonjour à tous
et direction la suède où une vidéo créé
l'indignation sur les réseaux sociaux
les publications évoque le kidnapping
d'un enfant musulman effectivement la
vidéo dure deux secondes on va la
découvrir ensemble on y voit un enfant
arrêté assez brutalement violemment
c'est vrai il peine à respirer et on
l'entend aussi récite en arabe la
chahada la profession de foi musulmane
et face à cette vidéo voici ce que nous
en dise certaines publications comme
celle ci qui nous dit que c'est un
enfant marocain arrêté ou kidnappés plus
exactement par les services sociaux
suédois et qui a tenté d'échapper à sa
famille d'accueil une fois pour voir ses
propres parents ses publications elle
date du 3 février et où depuis que des
images ont été partagés elles ont été
vues plus de 22 mille fois l'idée elle
est reprise par cet autre conte qui
insiste lui sur l'idée que les ce type
d'événement d'enlèvement plus
précisément se poursuit cette vidéo a
été mise en ligne sur cette publication
le 4 février elle a dépassé les cent
cinquante mille vue 180000 vue cette
fois pour cette publication fait en
français qui évoque l l'arrestation d'un
enfant musulman séparé de sa famille par
l'état suédois cette vidéo est
authentique mais elle a été dès
contextualiser travail c'est un
leitmotiv dans les techniques de
désinformation sortir la vidéo de son
contexte pour lui faire dire tout et
n'importe quoi surtout ce qu'on veut ça
n'enlève rien bien sûr à l'arrestation
et à la violence surtout de cette
arrestation mais une recherche d'image
l'inversé nous en apprend un peu plus
sur les circonstances
elle nous conduit d'abord à une vidéo du
10 février
2015 vidéos youtube et la légende nous
apprend qu'on est à malmö dans le sud de
la suède c'était écrit ici deux enfants
ce jour là l'un de 9 et de 12 ans on est
effectivement été arrêté par deux agents
de sécurité d'une compagnie privée
suédoise ce n'est donc pas à l'état il
s'était en fait échappés d'un centre
d'accueil un petit peu plus tôt ils ont
été expulsés d'un train dans lequel
n'avait pas payé leurs titres de
transport cette arrestation musclée
avait d'âge d'ailleurs fait l'objet de
nombreuses critiques à l'époque à la
fois dans les médias locaux et les
médias internationaux et les
observateurs de france 24 on avait
d'ailleurs réservé un article je vous
renvoie la radio publique suédoise avait
à ajouter à l'époque que ces deux
garçons musulmans était arrivé seul en
suède et qu'ils étaient hébergés dans
une maison d'accueil dans la tente de
leur demande d'asile et pour la petite
histoire sachez que cette vidéo elle a
déjà été décontextualisés cette fois en
2018 dans d'autres circonstances qui
l'ont été a attribué en l'occurrence
celle d'un enfant palestinien tué par la
police israélienne s'était donc en
novembre 2018 je vous renvoie à cet
article d'alexandre capron en tout cas
le gouvernement suédois s'est saisi du
dossier oui parce que le gouvernement
suédois a pris les choses effectivement
très au sérieux ils dénoncent une
campagne de désinformation
selon lui de nombreuses vidéos comme
celle ci dans lesquels alors non pas
comme celle ci parce que vous allez voir
pourquoi dans lesquels les services
sociaux justement prennent en charge des
enfants ce qui n'est pas le cas on le
rappelle dans celle de ce soir sont
justement diffusé et corrigé de telle
sorte qu'elles véhiculent l'idée que
donc les familles musulmans et les
musulmans en particulier sont ciblés on
retrouve même en ligne ce hashtag sur
twitter sur des comptes essentiellement
en arabe ou des internautes vont
dénoncer ce qui selon eux une volonté
délibérée des autorités suédoises de
séparer les familles musulmanes de leurs
enfants l'un fox de ce soir on la
retrouve par exemple sur ce compte
twitter affaires islamiques qui relaie a
régulièrement de la désinformation sur
le monde musulman avec un point de vue
assez conservateur avoir rigoriste et on
la retrouve aussi cette info qu' sur les
retrouve un certain écho en france c'est
vrai via notamment ce site qui se
présente je cite comme celui de toute
l'actualité francophone du musulman et
qui je cite toujours abbott d'abord de
manière neutre et apolitique tous les
sujets un site qui a été repéré par
l'observatoire du conspirationnisme
comme ayant diffusé à plusieurs reprises
des contenus conspirationnistes des
contenus faux et trompeur merci anthony
c'était info intox avec anthony st léger
rester avec nous on se retrouve dans
moins de dix minutes pour un nouveau
journal
[Musique]